[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce set 8
sociétés un peu particulier avec la
crise sanitaire les invités ne sont pas
en plateau avec moi mais sont présents
en visio nous allons ce soit révoqué les
oubliés du confinement
elle les personnes en situation de
handicap le corona virus et une pandémie
invisible avec lakovic 19 les personnes
en situation de handicap se sentent eux
aussi invisible est abandonnée pendant
le confinement leurs soins ont été
arrêtés avec nous pour en parler ce soir
béatrice piron député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines
bonsoir bonsoir laetitia pawlowski
psychomotricienne à vélizy-villacoublay
bonsoir mon isabelle olivier du
collectif andy actifs france et
présidente de l'association anaïs du
rêve à l'espoir bonsoir bonsoir et enfin
annick bouquay membres du comité
national consultatif du handicap et
président de l'association nouvelle du
vivre ensemble 78 bonsoir bonsoir un
chiffre clé est alarmant 87 87 % des
enfants handicapés n'ont eu aucune
stimulation pendant le confinement selon
un sondage du collectif andy actifs
france laetitia vous êtes
psychomotricienne et pendant le
confinement vous avez cessé votre
activité
quel est l'impact sur les personnes en
situation de handicap
oui alors tout à fait effectivement on a
cessé mon activité durant le confinement
ça a été vraiment soudain a pris au
niveau des percussions bas elles sont
multiples c'est à dire que sur le plan
fonctionnel
il est évident que les oranje ont des
difficultés de mouvement au niveau de
leur qualité la qualité puisque les
rééducations se sont arrêtés pendant
assez longtemps mais c'est également sur
toute la sphère psychoaffective qu'il y
a des répercussions avec de l'anxiété de
lentilles
et pardon par la perte des revers
notamment temporaux spatiaux puisque le
confinement nous a fait un peu perdre
tous ses repères man ou adultes et puis
et puis des difficultés aussi sur le
plan intentionnel parce que ces pertes
de repères favorise aussi toutes ces
difficultés là donc vraiment quelque
chose d'assez multiples en termes de
répercussions vous avez à garder le lien
avec vos passions vous avez notamment
envoyé des exercices par visio et c'est
donc aux parents de prendre le relais
oui alors surtout en temps de
psychomotricien où l'approché corporelle
il est évident que c'est extrêmement
compliqué de pouvoir favoriser une prise
en charge par vision parts et les soins
notamment que le téléthon n'a pas été
autorisé dans un premier temps s'est
avéré que ça a été le cas je pense que
de mémoire un mois après le début du
confinement
donc en attendant il a fallu maintenir
ou d'une autre façon donc soit par par
le téléphone par par mail également moi
j'ai personnellement favoriser le mail
et après des exercices qui était
accessible sur sur internet pour osi
permettre aux familles de ne pas
surcharger les les familles qui ont eu
beaucoup de choses à gérer pendant son
film en est à l'heure du décompte
finement 52 % des enfants n'ont toujours
pas bénéficié de séances de rééducation
ou seulement partiellement
concernant l'éducation depuis la fin du
confinement et 40% des enfants n'ont été
accueillie que partiellement à l'école
tandis que 4 5% n'ont pas été autorisés
à y retourner du fait de leur handicap
béatrice pire on vous fait partie de la
commission d' enquête sur l'inclusion
des élèves handicapés avec le sondage
une réaction est ce que c'est pas un
délai supplémentaire pour ces personnes
qui n'ont déjà
une pas de séance pendant le confinement
alors deux points de vue de la scolarité
de l'école on a de suite demandé à ce
que les enfants en situation de handicap
soit prioritaire et ils ont toujours
fait partie des publics prioritaires
pour le premier retour à l'école donc au
11 mai quand les écoles ont réouvert
donc bon évidemment il y avait le choix
des parents qui mettaient leurs enfants
à l'école non mais normalement il
pouvait être accueillis donc vous
détient 4% des enfants en situation
d'handicap pour lequel ça n'a pas
fonctionné idéalement donc j'imagine
peut-être qu'il ya eu des avs qui était
ou d un message qui étaient en situation
de fragilité qui ne pouvait pas
reprendre leurs activités
professionnelles et c'est vrai que
toutes ces personnes pour ces adultes
avaient aussi des droits de te mettre
donc en art et s'il était en situation
fragile mais dans la grande majorité des
cas les enfants étaient accueillis à
n'évoquer vous vous organisez des
olympiades du vivre ensemble à
versailles retourner à l'école pour ses
enfants en situation de handicap
retrouver une vie sociale à l'extérieur
c'est important mais comme tous les
autres enfants
c'est pour moi c'est les mêmes c'est ils
ont exactement les mêmes droits cédés
comment 10 et des sujets des sujets
droit avant d'être des êtres des objets
de soin donc ils ont exactement les
mêmes droits que les autres enfants et
je confirmerai ce que dit madame piron
c'est à dire moi je suis aussi je statut
d'être adjointe à la petite enfance et
la seule chose qui nous les contraintes
qu'on n'a pas pu accepter tous les
enfants c'est le personnel c'est un
personnel qui était fragile et qui
pouvait pas non plus revenir c'était
aussi notre contrat voilà et puis aussi
le choix à certains parents de pas
mettre leur enfant ils avaient l'olivier
vous êtes la merde anaïs 9 ans et demi
elle est atteinte d'une infirmité
motrice cérébrale depuis la naissance et
elle n'a pas eu de soins pendant le
confinement
j'ai pu suivre votre quotidien regardez
ce reportage
je te donne ta tablette ça c'est le
support que papa fabriqué pour lui
éviter de trop baisser la tête on en
parle peu lors de cette crise sanitaire
les personnes handicapées leurs
difficultés depuis le confinement
isabelle olivier la merde anaïs 9 ans et
demi elle a eu un accident à la
naissance en fait elle souffre de
paralysie cérébrale
elle a eu un manque d'oxygène qui a
provoqué la pas réalisé de ses quatre
membres les jambes les bras et elle a
aussi un problème au niveau de la parole
puisqu'elle a des difficultés à
articuler habituellement entouré d'une
équipe spécialisée anaïs est désormais
toute la journée à la maison depuis ses
deux ans anaïs fait des stages de
rééducation à l'étranger grâce aux dons
récoltés mais avec le coronavirus les
manifestations ont été annulées
les fonds servent aussi pour le matériel
médical nécessaire et les travaux
adaptés pour anaïs ici on ya fait une
salle de bains une douche à l'italienne
avec des vitres pour que je puisse la
douche et s'en sont même mouillé ça
c'est sa chambre et c'est son lit
médicalisé qu'est la seule chose que
l'on a pu avoir en location anaïs 9 ans
et demi s'intéresse à beaucoup de choses
de son âge mais pour cette mère de
famille c'est une éducation différente
avec beaucoup de frais à sa charge le
fauteuil de douche lui coûtait 1 900
euros et le siège modulable 6000 euros
en fait la mdph nous a remboursé zéro
euro pour récolter des fonds il a bel
olivier a créé l'association analyse du
rêve à l'esport en janvier 2017
elle est investie également dans le
collectif andy actifs france si on
n'avait pas récolté réussi à récolter
tous ces fonds je serais vraiment enfin
complètement déprimé oui abandonné
abandonnés par l'état ça c'est sûr anaïs
on va faire l'orthophonie d'accord avec
le confinement tout est à distance à
l'aide de sa souris de son clavier
adapté cet exercice ludique permet de
pousser anaïs à faire un maximum de
phrases mais sur ok pendant le
confinement toutes les séances de
rééducation d'anaïs ont été arrêtés la
petite fille a perdu en motricité
pendant ces six semaines
c'est vrai qu' on aurait aimé quelqu'un
vienne à domicile pour pour lui donner
des séances mais malheureusement elle
n'en a pas eu
les parents d'anaïs ont dû prendre le
relais et ont pratiqué des séances de
tabata par visio l'arrêt des soins a eu
de lourdes conséquences
isabelle olivier a eu plusieurs
casquettes pendant ce confinement mère
de famille professeur éducatrice elle
alerte sur les conditions des aidants ça
demande beaucoup de temps il fallait
aussi en même temps faire à manger faire
le ménage faire les courses
et en plus les
les activités que l'on a l'habitude de
faire en tant qu'aidant anaïs pèse 30 kg
donc qu'elle est assez lourde à
manipuler et là depuis un an je fais des
tendinites chroniques comme vous pouvez
le voir j'ai une ceinture lombaire parce
que j'ai mal au dos donc oui c'est à ça
a été vraiment une épreuve avec le
collectif andy actifs france elles
demandent à l'état que tous les parents
ayant gardé sans relais leur enfant
handicapé pendant le confinement puisse
toucher eux aussi une prime d'urgence de
1500 euros
on l'a vu l'impact de la crise qu vite
sur le quotidien des familles touchées
par le handicap est multiple le
collectif andy actifs france réclament
une prime de 1500 euros ainsi que la
création d'un véritable statut d'aidant
assortie d'une reconnaissance de leur
travail et des difficultés auxquelles
ils sont confrontés bat respirons vous
êtes favorable à cette prime de 1500
euros
alors on à en accorder des primes à tous
les professionnels aux salariés dans les
hôpitaux les maisons de retraite
également les intervenants domicile qui
ont travaillé pendant la faillite
mais ces primes ne peuvent être donnée
que dans le cadre d'un contrat travail
et aujourd'hui effectivement donc n'est
pas envisagé de donner une prime aux
parents ou aux aidants familiaux qui ont
aidé comme comme une aide tout au long
de l'année aussi pour la prise en charge
de leurs enfants même s'ils étaient
supérieurs à leur prise en charge
habituelle mais sur du long terme ou de
façon générale le gouvernement fait tout
pour essayer d'aider les aidants
familiaux
donc il ya eu déjà des textes de lois
qui sont allés dans ce sens là pour pour
améliorer les aides qui sont données à
la fois donc aux personnes en situation
de handicap mais aussi aux familles par
exemple la 1e 2 h
donc s'il qui permet à des parents
d'enfants handicapés d'avoir des
allocations pour pouvoir mieux aider
leurs enfants
il ya également tout ce qui est congé de
proches aidants qui a été mise en place
qui sera effectif à partir du mois
d'octobre donc prochainement qui va
pouvoir permettre donc à des familles de
prendre des congés rémunérés donc
partiellement ou
pour pouvoir s'occuper soin de leurs
parents soin de leurs enfants dans
certaines situations difficiles il avait
l'olivier une réaction alors oui
justement je voudrais revenir sur le
coran j'ai deux projets dans qui
s'adresse à des aidants familiaux mais
absolument pas aux aidants familiaux de
personnes ou d'enfants en situation de
handicap puisqu'il n'est il est bon pour
le moment il encore rémunérés mais les
durées maximum je crois de trois mois
rémunéré ou de 1 an et c'est absolument
pas le besoin qui est pris en compte
d'un enfant handicapé qu'il est qu'il
sera toute sa vie donc les parents
besoin d'un congé bien plus bien plus
conséquent et concernant la hache le
gros problème c'est qu'il y a des
disparités entre les mdph pour faire
valoir nos droits on fait les calculs ne
sont pas du tout les mêmes certaines
mdph sont plus généreuses que d'autres
mais de toute façon en aucun cas elles
ne reflètent réellement le temps que
l'on passe à nous occuper de notre
enfant en fait il faut se battre en
permanence contre la mdph madame je
voulais c'est un répondre dans un
instant annick bouquay peut être une
réaction non c'est vrai que d'un
territoire à l'autre les d'ailleurs je
pense que le gouvernement travaille
dessus moi je sais qu'au niveau du cncph
on en parle beaucoup de cette diversité
de réponse en fonction des mdph mais je
crois qu'il ya un gros travail qui va
être fait et un programme qui s'appelle
je vois là et on peut pas l'évoquer
peut-être par la suite justement pour
uniformiser ça et qu'ils aient les
meilleures réponses locales en fonction
des besoins des parents mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des différences d'un d'un
département à l'autre on peut leur le
dia bâ nous rayonnons et respirons en
tant que député de la 3e circonscription
des yvelines sur ces inégalités de
territoire madame vous qui donc a déjà
parlé de ce projet 360 donc il existe
maintenant le numéro de téléphone 0 800
x 160 360 qui permet donc à toutes les
familles d'obtenir une aide concrète
pour avancer dans les démarches et
justement régler ses problèmes
d'inégalité entre les départements parce
qu'effectivement ce sont des aides
départementales et au jeu
chaque département est souverain et
décide des choses différemment mais il
ya un gros effort pour que les choses
soient harmonisées donc il va y avoir d
harmonisation des formulaires et des
documents réclamés donc pour la mise en
place des aides il ya une harmonisation
des logiciels qui vise justement
permettront de transférer des dossiers
d'un département à l'autre
donc le projet n'est pas toujours à
l'état d'avancement je vais vous
souhaiterez mais tant qu'il avance et on
part dans la bonne direction je pense
concernant donc le congé de proches
aidants effectivement c'est un congé qui
est qui qui est que ponctuelle qui ne
peut pas être de longue durée mais ça
peut permettre à même d'aider à mettre
en place donc des nouvelles solutions
quand l'état de santé de la personne
évolue change et de trouver donc une
solution adaptée pour après de façon
pérenne voir fonctionner l'éthicien en
tant que psychomotricienne vous avez pu
voir également ses inégalités
oui ça fait partie du quotidien et
surtout dans le domaine libéral de la
petite halle motricité qui ait un sens
qui n'est pas remboursé par la sécurité
sociale
donc effectivement les disparités
existent
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup d'efforts qui
a beaucoup de choses mis en place pour
pouvoir justement lycée cette espagne et
mais le la réalité encore c'est que les
disparités sont toujours présents pour
pallier à ces disparités en france
isabelle olivier avec votre conjoint
vous avez décidé de faire appel à des
sciences non reconnues par la médecine
officielle mais qui fonctionne sur anaïs
la méthode est senti ça se passe à
l'étranger en espagne ou en pologne des
déplacements et des voyages qui coûte
cher et avec lakovic 19 les événements
pour récolter les fonds ont été annulés
est-ce que anaïs pourra partir cette
année
alors avec l'ouverture des frontières à
partir du 1er juillet elle devrait
partir effectivement en espagne au mois
d'août en est on à un voyage également
de prévue en pologne
donc pendant le confinement nous avions
prévu d'aller à et santis au mois
d'avril donc ce voyage a effectivement
été annulés mais là on espère qu'il y
aura pas de confinement interne comme il
peut y avoir actuellement en espagne et
qu'elle pourra bénéficier de ces
rééducation parce que c'est vrai que
tous ces mois sens en rééducation sans
effort physique en fait qu'elle a perdu
en stabilité qui a des douleurs qui
n'existait pas qui sont apparues et
c'est vraiment vital pour un enfant pour
un adulte en situation de handicap de
bouger en permanence de faire des
exercices en permanence c'est vraiment
vital laetitia en tant que psycho
motricienne à vélizy quel est votre
regard sur ces traitements à l'étranger
et en quoi consistent ces séances alors
personnellement moi je ne connais pas
exactement en quoi consistent ces
séances de rééducation j'en ai entendu
parler et je sais que elles sont assez
complètes et assez intensive
maintenant effectivement il serait
profitable de pouvoir découvrir il ya
une multitude de méthodes aujourd'hui
qui existe dans les rééducations et mon
peu de choses qui sont je dirais
homogénéiser sur sur les territoires
donc on sait que c'est toujours les
parents qui nous font découvrir ce genre
de rééducation batterie chapiron quand
vous entendez que des familles partent à
l'étranger doivent partir ça veut dire
qu'en france il y a un certain retard
alors bon je ne suis pas spécialiste de
ses problèmes de santé et je ne connais
pas le cas de cette petite fille donc
j'ai du mal à prononcer moi ce que je
sais c'est que sur nos territoires on a
quand même des solutions et beaucoup de
choses sont faites et des beaucoup de
choses existe alors est-ce qu'ils sont
parfaitement adaptés ou pas aux cas
d'année je ne sais pas mais j'ai super g
dames 1 circonscription par exemple un
très grand centre donc qui est lui-même
de bailly que madame olivier connais
peut-être qui a qui reçoit à plus d'une
centaine d'enfants donc en situation
on de handicap cérébral et on fait
beaucoup dont ils ont décliné ils ont
des piscines il fonde de l'équitation
dans certains cas ils ont des
équipements et beaucoup de
professionnels à l'heure soit ils ont
même réouvert pendant la période de
confinement dont ils ont repris des
enfants pour justement éviter que la
l'interruption de soins soit trop
prolongé donc à partir de fin avril donc
les enfants ont pu à tour de rôle par
demi-journée réintégrer le centre donc
c'est un centre qui accueille les
enfants en journée normalement où ils
sont scolarisés où il ya des enseignants
de l'éducation nationale qui leur
apprennent à lire et à écrire
et moi j'ai rencontré de nombreux
enfants qui pour qui ça se passait bien
donc je connais pas tous les cas
possibles mais on on essaie de faire au
mieux de trouver des solutions pour tous
les enfants isabelle olivier
l'accompagnement est suffisant
insuffisant alors il est vraiment
insuffisant alors je connais vie même de
bailly même si ma fille n'est pas prise
en charge là bas le gros souci en fait
de ces centres c'est qu'il y à un manque
de thérapeutes 1 tout simplement parce
que il ya beaucoup de turnover les
thérapeutes partent parce qu'ils sont
mal payés il faut le dire
ce qui fait que souvent et bien quand il
manque un ou deux kinés on est obligé de
se partager qui met entre plein
d'enfants ce qui fait qu'en moyenne les
les enfants n'ont par exemple que deux à
trois séances dans la semaine de
rééducation alors peut-être cabaye ils
en ont un peu plus mais sur la france
ils ont à peu près deux séances de
rééducation en moyenne et c'est un
constat qu'a également fait la fondation
motrice qui s'occupe de la paralysie
cérébrale dans une enquête nommé est ce
parce qu'elle a fait il y a deux ans
donc il ya des soucis donc financier
parce qu'effectivement les mails et le
personnel ne peut pas partir il ya des
soucis de formation parce que toutes ces
rééducation qui sont faites à l'étranger
on ne propose pas des formations en
france pour former les thérapeutes et
dans leur cursus scolaire on ne forme
pas non plus à la parra
cérébrale donc c'est également
problématique et comme le disait
laetitia c'est que la psychomotricité
l'ergothérapie sont des rééducations qui
ne sont pas prises en charge par la
sécurité sociale
donc quand on en a pas suffisamment dans
les centres il faut aller faire faire
c'est rééducation mois en ville la seule
problématique c'est que ce n'est pas
remboursé
annick bouquay une réaction sur ses
prises en charge
oui alors je dirai juste je connais
aussi très bien le centre de ben ali
comme je reconnais d'autres mais je peux
alors peut-être que c'est propre à
wailly à certains centres
mais je peux vous dire que les
kinésithérapeutes les airs côté atteint
après par exemple de bailly sont depuis
très longtemps là et c'est toujours les
mêmes ça n'a pas bougé je vois là c'est
je cours avec eux avec dunes d'espoir et
ils sont là depuis plus de dix ans ça je
peux vous le certifier
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une diversité
de formes de handicap
on le sait bien il ya une diversité de
besoins très spécifiques
peut-être que oui il faut peut-être que
on a eu aussi s'inspirer de ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur dans les formations
des kinésithérapeutes ergothérapeutes
c'est mais ça veut pas dire non plus que
ce qu'on fait n'est pas bien non plus
parce que moi je vois des enfants qui
évoluent aussi très très bien et qui
suivent des traitements
j'en veux dire franco-français mais mes
façons il faut toujours s'améliorer
c'est évident et à l'issue du
confinement 80 % des parents d'enfants
en situation de handicap se disent en
burn-out isabelle olivier vous avez on
l'a vu pendant le reportage plusieurs
blessures des tendinites des déchirures
musculaires
un petit tour de table sur la prise en
charge et sur les aidants alors
effectivement je vous confirme là ce
matin je viens de repasser une
échographie j'ai bien une tendinite
chronique au niveau de l'épaule et c'est
je ne suis pas la seule
et dante familiale qu'il ya des
problèmes physiques de dos des pôles de
poignet donc dans leur effectivement
dans le
dans le sondage il ya 75 % des parents
qui ont des douleurs musculaires et là
je parle pas aussi de tout ce qui est
d'où leur moral des personnes qui sont
déprimés qu'ils sont en burn out et le
confinement en a énormément aggraver la
situation puisqu'il ya des parents qui
physiquement ne pouvait pas s'occuper de
leurs enfants et qui ont fait vraiment
de grosses dépressions laetitia
pawlowski vous avez également des
remontées des des parents de vos
passions oui tout à fait ça a été une
situation qui a été quand même difficile
et puis longue
donc voilà c'est ce sont des parents et
des aidants qui ont dû démultiplier
leurs casquettes et leur énergie donc
forcément une fatigue importante à
l'issue de de cet épisode et est encore
une fois même chez les enfants voient
dans de l'anxiété on voit aussi les
répercussions du déconfinement pu être
visible effectivement c'est quelque
chose
c'est une situation exceptionnelle et je
pense que voilà on a tous été sidéré au
début un peu de ce confinement on s'est
tous adaptés comme comme on a pu mais
messi mais il faudra quand même qu'on
progresse on progresse là dessus pas un
bouquet je suis tout à fait d'accord je
pense que c'était une période très très
dur pour les pour les parents pour les
aidants ça a été très compliqué je pense
qu'il faut qu'on en tire des leçons
voilà il faut vraiment qu'on soit si une
crise
ce que je ne souhaite pas reviennent il
faut vraiment qu'on soit présent à leurs
côtés d'une forme ou d'une autre parce
que je pense que ça a été très difficile
pour moi j'en suis certaine
m piron que répondez vous enfin ça à
tous a également donc on l'a vu la
rupture de soins pendant le confinement
mais aussi pour les aidants plusieurs
casquettes éducateurs enseignants
professeurs qui ne leurs blessures
que faire quand pidement été difficile
pour toutes les familles et encore plus
pour celles qui avaient des enfants en
situation de handicap mais on a pu quand
même constaté qu'il y avait qu un gros
élan de générosité de volontariat parmi
les français beaucoup se sont engagés
auprès d'associations pour donner un
coup de main pour aller faire des
courses pour pour faire ce que l'on peut
aider dans la mesure de nos compétences
et nos capacités
donc je crois qu'il faut quand même
aussi être reconnaissant par rapport à
cette croisée gros élan de générosité
des français qui ont accepté d'aller
aider leurs voisins et de contribuer et
donc je crois que c'est quelque chose de
bien
après du point de vue de l'état c'était
très délicat on nous a reproché de
descons fini est trop tôt ou trop tard
longtemps confiné même si beaucoup de
parents ont été réticents est très
anxieux et ne voulait pas remettre leurs
enfants à l'école on a pourtant insisté
et expliquer aux familles comme quoi il
était important pour les enfants aussi
de retrouver un lieu de sociabilisation
leurs camarades de classe
même si le virus est encore présent en
france il est important pour eux de
pouvoir revivre normalement le plus
normalement possible et j'espère que
tous ces parents pour trouver une
solution une solution de répit pour
l'été pour avoir droit à quelques
vacances et et s'organiser pour pouvoir
justement retrouver une vie normale et
une santé après cette période évidemment
très difficile
merci merci à toutes les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce 7,8 société c'est la fin
de cette émission elle est à retrouver
en replay sur notre site internet à
mercredi prochain très bonne soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
on
merci